- But basically you think
you require money to be rich?
- Well you can also be rich in love.
I'm feel like I'm already
rich in happiness.
- Good.
- Because I have nice friends,
I have a nice family, and
I have a pretty nice life.
I'm actually pretty spoiled.
- Don't tell your mother
and father, right? (laughs)
(suspenseful music)
- [Interviewer] I am afraid of death.
Those who agree, please step forward.
(kids giggles)
- Oh okay.
I wanna sit in the middle.
- I'm in the middle.
- Like I feel like life is really short
and you have so much to
achieve in that period
and in that short period
you need to show the world your purpose.
- Yeah, it's like I actually
had a close death experience
not that long ago and that was scary.
So I'm gonna say it is even scarier
to actually have it happen!
- Well, death is probably
gonna be scary for me,
because I'm a crybaby.
I can barely handle height.
If you wanted me to like
be on a rollercoaster,
I will be crying even before it started.
- Yeah, but like the thing is
that if you don't take risks,
how will your life journey be rewarding?
Like if you guys are afraid of heights,
what if you try to overcome it?
And what if that makes
your life more memorable?
- I try to, but I kind of did enjoy it,
but at the same time it
felt like I'm about to die.
(cowbell hits)
- [Interviewer] Now can I have
the disagree or step forward?
- Hello, disagreers.
- Death is part of living.
It happens to everybody, to
some people sooner than others,
but the important thing is
to try and live your life
how you think you want to live it.
- I don't know how I want to live it.
- It's not an easy thing when
you lose someone you love.
You learn to live without them
and hopefully you've gained something
from your relationship with those people.
- I agree with you, it
just, and I honestly thought
that I was ready for death until,
if I'm like bleeding, I'm
already like scared and crying
and I'm already thinking that I'm dying
if I'm already bleeding.
- But death is just a part of life.
I equate death sometimes with a tree.
What is happening to the trees now
with their leaves?
- They're falling.
That's right.
They're getting ready for new leaves
to come in the springtime
and it's just a natural part of life.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Now that I'm getting
to my twilight years,
I am wondering what is going
to happen after I pass away.
And that is the thing that I think about
more than anything else.
(cowbell hits)
I'm not a believer of God,
and I am always just
wondering what is the purpose
of being born and what is
going to be the hereafter?
That is something of course no one
will be able to give
you an answer on that.
But I do believe in reincarnation.
I feel that I'm coming back
to earth as maybe a newborn
or maybe as an animal
or something like that.
(cowbell hits)
- In our religion we have
something called karma.
So it's your good deeds come back to you
and your bad deeds in the
afterlife come back to affect you,
and that's why I feel
like the period you have
from like being a child growing up,
you know, just progressing
through life, it's so important.
But still like that thought
lingers in the back of my mind.
Is there something that
will come to affect me?
- Well, you know, my
son-in-love father died,
and I flew back to Oklahoma
City for his funeral
and I did not see one wet
eye in that funeral service.
Everybody was laughing, joking around,
because that's the way that Pawpaw lived.
And I left their thinking,
"I don't want people crying over me.
I want them to be happy for
me and happy for themselves."
- And if you go to see,
let's say, a gravestone
and there's a dash between 1900 and 1970,
the most important thing is that dash.
- What happened during that dash?
- Yes.
- The time that you lived
and what you were able to accomplish,
and what kind of a legacy
did you leave to your family
and your heirs is very,
very important to me.
(wind whooshes)
- [Interviewer] I have been in love.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] Those
who agree, step forward.
- Opposite this time!
It's opposite this time!
- Unless you're counting family members.
- Actually, yeah.
- I suppose neither
one of you are married.
(group laughs)
- No!
It's love in a different way.
Love is, it's such a interesting force.
It brings people together.
It separates people but like still, yeah,
of course I have close ones
and I do dearly love them.
- But love can also be that dagger
in your heart.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you're totally right.
- Well for me, yes, love
can be hard because for me,
loved ones, we usually fight more
than I fight with a normal person,
but for me that just shows
that you really love them.
Like I love my family because
they're really nice to me
and they really care for me.
- That's wonderful.
But what if they did not treat you nicely?
- Well, they're still my family.
I still gotta love 'em.
- And you still love them.
That's right.
- I am very fortunate.
I've been married to this
lovely woman for 63 years.
- Wow!
- Oh my god!
- So that is virtually a lifetime.
We have three daughters,
seven grandchildren,
and three great-grandchildren.
- Somebody asked me,
"how is it that you managed
to be married for 63 years?"
And I answered, "love
is a different story."
Love is a person who cares about you,
you care about that person.
If you're married a long time,
you experience a lot of things
and some of 'em are very difficult,
and a lot of them are really wonderful.
So I always told our children,
"you have to make time
for all the good times."
(cowbell hits)
- I love my family, my parents,
my pets and everything,
but when people say like in love
I've like never had like
a crush or anything.
I've never had like a
boyfriend or girlfriend.
No, none of that, no.
I feel glad that I'm not in love yet
because I don't at all feel ready.
I wanna be those people
who don't have a crush,
and nobody has a crush on
them, because that's weird!
Like that makes me, that like
probably makes people think
that I'm cool and then it
makes them have a crush on me
and then they'll get a crush on me
and then I'll have like an army
of 20 boys following me around.
I'm like, "ah!"
- Do you think that in the future
the love that your family gives you
is equal to that of a love
that a partner would give you?
Like these guys definitely
love each other so much
and I think the love of your guys' family,
plus your guys' connection with each other
were the reasons you guys got
through hard times together.
- I mean it could be true
that they love me as much as my family,
like in six years from now
when I actually started
dating or something.
The love and the things
your family teaches you
are really like gonna
stay with you forever
even though a lover might not.
(air whooshes)
- [Interviewer] People are mostly good.
- I think that deep within everybody,
there is good inside them,
except it's with some people
they haven't found themselves yet in life
to be able to show their goodness.
- I would like to think
that everyone is good.
But when I look at the news.
- Ooh.
- For example, a family
completely annihilated
just a few days ago.
Where was the goodness in that man
who murdered these people?
- So addressing that.
You guys have all probably
faced bullying, right?
- Oh, yes.
- So the person who
bullies another person,
they have something that's affecting them,
whether it be like their personal issues,
issues with their family,
and that kind of, in the future,
makes them resort to
means that aren't good.
And sometimes it's not their fault.
It could be of their mental health issues,
it could be because of the background,
like if they've been abused
when they were young.
Just because you do bad
things in the future,
you annihilated, you commit crimes.
I don't think that means
that you're a bad person.
I just think that means you're not showing
the good side of you,
you're showing the bad side.
- A lot of it could be
a mental illness too.
- Yes.
- And there are a lot of people
who have that mental illness
and therefore can't show their good side.
- There are a lot of good people,
and you may be right,
maybe everybody has
the ability to be good,
but some people don't exercise it.
And again, there are people who, I think,
somebody kills someone,
of course they're sick.
That's gotta be something mentally wrong
that you're going to kill somebody.
(air whooshes)
45 years ago, we were followed home,
and when we got home, we
were held up with a gun
and he said he was going to kill me.
So he took my ring and
took my husband's car keys.
And right now, it's worse.
The children are not safe.
Our children are our future.
If they're not safe, who is?
And it's not getting better.
They're not, it's happening more and more.
It's horrible.
So no, I don't think it's safe now.
(cowbell dings)
- Well, for me, I kind of disagree,
because yes, there is good in people,
but people can be very bad
whether we like it or not.
Because for me, I do have a bad side.
It might be just because I
get like angry really easily,
but I can think mean thoughts too,
but I try not to say it.
I get mad easily whether
you believe it or not.
I will literally scream at you.
One time when my friend was called a brat,
I was about to go full
crazy on that person,
but instead I tried to be nice.
But I couldn't help it, I was like...
- I do think there is mostly
good people in the world.
Actually everybody in the world is good,
but the bad people just
wanna show their bad side.
So then they're just the bad people
that we think about when
we think bad people,
because they did things
they weren't supposed to
and they did it 'cause they wanted to.
- I was always taught the golden rule.
- Treat others-
- Treat others the way
you way you wanna be treated.
- That's right.
I would like to be treated kindly,
and I would hope that people
are teaching their children that.
(air whooshes)
- [Interviewer] I would love to be rich.
- Well, for me, I'd love to be rich,
because let's say I have
like a million dollars.
I can invest in stocks first,
and then I can like start a business,
and then I can make more money.
And then the more money that I get,
I can also help other people.
Like I can help poor people,
I can donate to charities,
and I can also help out
myself and other people.
- But basically you think
you require money to be rich.
- Well, you can also be rich in love with-
- But you can be rich in other
things and what you have.
- Like a great personality too.
- Yes.
I think I am rich,
because I'm blessed
with a wonderful family.
- I think that a lot
of times what happens,
people think of accumulating wealth,
which is a sign of happiness.
And happiness to me is, there's one word.
It's contentment.
If you are content with your
life and what you're doing,
I think you're then very, very
happy and very, very rich.
- I'm feel like I'm
already rich in happiness.
- [Millee] Good.
Because I have nice friends
and I have a nice family
and I have a pretty nice life.
I'm actually pretty spoiled actually.
- But don't tell your mother
and father, right? (laughs)
(cowbell hits)
- Where you going?
- I'm going to-
All right, well I was going to, sorry.
- Oh, oh.
- That's all right.
- Thank you.
You are truly a gentleman.
Thank you.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
- I'm gonna steal him.
- You're gonna try!
(both laugh)
- Okay, well I think it
would be cool to be rich,
but when I think of rich,
I think of kind of selfish
people with golden cars,
mansions, show off.
When I think of rich people, I
think of kind of mean people.
- Not all rich people are mean.
I mean I know that's not what you meant,
but I know that you only think
about the mean rich people,
but not everybody that is rich is mean.
- Yeah, but I mean like most
of them are like show off,
because they're like, "I have
so much more money than you.
Yeah. I have a mansion.
I'm a millionaire."
No, I don't like mean people,
so that is not really what I like.
- One of my favorite authors, he said,
"it is with the heart
that one can see rightly.
What is essential is
invisible to the eyes."
- Oh!
- I think money's materialistic,
and as you said, materialistic
things in my life
don't matter to me.
It's more of trust your
friends, your support system,
your family, things that matter to you.
Things that can only
be seen with the heart,
not with your eyes.
- I like that, and I agree with you.
(air whooshes)
- [Interviewer] Life is difficult.
- Life is difficult.
- Oh yes, it is.
- Yes, life is difficult.
- Thank you.
Chivalry is not dead.
He's very chivalrous.
- Life is hard!
Like as a kid having very bad anxiety,
which does not help with how hard life is,
there is smooth sailing,
and then something bad
just strikes up at you
and you aren't ready,
and then it all happens all over again.
It is very, very hard to do that.
- Life has its seasons,
just like winter,
spring, summer, and fall.
You have to really be strong
to go through those rough seasons.
But yeah, life can be tough.
It can be tough.
Yeah.
- I also think that your
lives were kind of harder
than ours now because like for research,
instead of like reading a book
and looking for the right specific page,
we could do that, but we
can also just like internet,
and then we can find exactly
what we're looking for.
Also, the rights that we have.
Back then, if I'm correct
like around the 1930s to the 1940s,
life was hard, because of
segregation, of discrimination,
of women's rights, and in some sense,
I feel like that today's
life is somewhat easier.
- Well guess what, Neil?
I think that kids are
having it rough today.
And I am so glad I'm not of
this generation. (laughs)
- I've been bullied.
Some have been because of my culture,
because of the food I eat,
because of the clothes that I wear.
People think that I'm different from them.
- [Interviewer] How do
you react to such bullies?
- You can't stress on these small things,
these small nuances.
Instead of reacting to what
they're saying, I ignore it.
And usually that turns out
to be the best solution.
(cowbell dings)
- Well, life happens.
- That's right.
- And you have to deal with it.
- Mm hmm.
- You can't say, "why
did that happen to me?"
Why not?
Why not you?
What's so different that
it shouldn't happen to you?
You can't feel sorry for
yourself when something happens.
- That's right.
- You have to help yourself.
And it's how you deal
with the difficult time
that's important.
- Yeah.
- Because you have to go
forward, not backward.
- I just wanted to say quickly
(ethereal ambient music)
that you guys were all really wise.
You guys have had ups and downs,
you guys have had hardships.
and I was very fortunate
to talk to you guys.
Thank you.
Yeah.
- Thank you.
- I'm not worried about the future,
because you are the future.
I would encourage you all
to interview your elders,
because you don't want
to miss out on anything,
any facts about your family.
- For me, my parting words is that
I hope you all have a good day now.
Like not even just a
good day, a good life.
- Thank you.
And we hope we do too,
and we hope your life is wonderful,
a life full of interest.
- [Interviewer] All right, thank you.
You can clap for yourselves.
(group claps)
- Very, very nice meeting you.
- Nice meeting you.
- Nice meeting all of you!